we've braved the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace
and the norms and notions of what just
is isn't always just
this you remember that amanda gorman
stole the show at this year's
presidential inauguration
before she took the stage at the capitol
and landed on the cover of magazines
like vogue and time
gorman was honored as the first national
youth poet laureate back in
2017 well this spring the arts group
urban word announced this year's
national youth poet laureate
jan crawford is at the martin luther
king jr memorial library in washington
with more on the young honoree
jan good morning well her name is
alexandra
nguyen and at 18 years old this
inspiring young woman
is ready to share her ideas for making
the world a better place through what
she calls her superpower
poetry it does not matter
any longer where you live from news
reports on the fires in california
and the floods in vietnam poet alexander
huan is
telling her story of a california
childhood
interrupted by climate change the forest
is a city
with wildfire for veins and a steady
churn of smog
and the pride she feels as a vietnamese
american
in the country my mother loves and its
naked heart
poetry has opened up a world of
possibility to this shy
rising college freshman when amanda
gorman was
crowned the inaugural national youth
poet laureate i thought to myself oh
that's so cool
couldn't be me though so you never even
thought
hey maybe no i never thought it was
possible
drumroll please but in may of this year
it was her hailing from sacramento
california it's just this
overwhelming why and i think i'm still
asking myself that question
why why me why am i here the why starts
with her parents
donghuin and tau nguyen who are high
school sweethearts in vietnam before
immigrating to the u.s to pursue higher
education
alex grew up with her three siblings and
two working parents in sacramento
oh look at that nice has it sunk in for
you as a mom
i'm very proud of alexandra and i never
dreamed that i would be a mom of such a
national figure like that what does that
mean to you
that means that all the hard work that
we put in to raise our children
pay off her parents say alex has always
been
introverted preferring to observe rather
than speak
but as a kid she took singing lessons
and after a while i got kind of restless
because i was thinking
why am i singing all these songs that
weren't written for me that can't
show the nuance of my lived experiences
i just thought to myself well why don't
i just
write what i want to see i think poetry
and songwriting has allowed me to
write myself into existence and give
myself a say
when alex found her voice she realized
she had a lot to say
about equality climate change and
identity
when you talk about your identity you
wanted to show that your culture was
something
that was not necessary to be quote
overcome yes 100
i think that in hearing my story people
might be quick to applaud me
because they believe that asian culture
is stifling especially to
female voices but i never spoke up not
because i felt like i was going to be
punished
it's just that no one asked me what i
was thinking so no one
asked no one asked and that's just a
larger testament to the fact that
there are so many young people who walk
around with these amazing thoughts in
their head and because
no one tells them that their voice
matters they don't see any point in
sharing it
yes that could be anyone that could mean
everything your sister has said that she
thinks that you seem so much more
confident
when you're performing poetry do you
feel that
i do when i'm on stage i don't feel
scared
of messing up because i don't think i
could ever forget words that i wrote
myself
and as a little girl she found herself
identifying with disney's
hannah montana a show about a normal
teenage girl who lived a secret life
as a pop star i was really intrigued by
the idea of a double life
because i kind of felt like i was
leading one in my head
i was very opinionated and i always had
something to say but
on the outside i did what everyone
expected me to do
and i've been trying to find a way to
mesh those two halves together because
it can be kind of
excruciating when you feel like the
person that is being perceived isn't the
person that's inside of your head
yeah because you're not feel like you're
being true to yourself yeah absolutely
i think i was so drawn to hannah montana
because she found a way
to make to make that second identity a
reality
and maybe that's what i'm doing with
poetry i'm
i'm writing my truest self in an attempt
to make it
you know my everyday self the men on the
news say climate change
is a hoax i talk back hold the objects
they inhabit
break them now that she has a national
platform
alex wants to reach back and make sure
other people's voices
also are heard i feel incredibly
privileged to be here
i know that it took a lot of work on my
behalf but i also know that
my community has put in just as much if
not more work by
mentoring me and really giving me access
to
spaces where i felt like my voice
mattered so
it's the win of my entire community the
vietnamese american community
sacramento i'm just so happy to
to uplift their stories now this fall
alex will study engineering at stanford
university and she plans to
use that training to put into action
some of the ideas that she shares in her
poetry
of bettering her community and building
a more sustainable and equitable world
from the ground up she also dreams of
writing a book of poetry
that will be translated into her first
language vietnamese
wow dan crawford reporting and
introducing us to a very graceful young
voice on the american
stage we'll be hearing about her in the
future i'm sure for sure
on this show i think